die erde wird schon bald untergehen in
astronomischen dimensionen schon in
knapp einer milliarde jahre wird es auf
unserem planeten viel zu heiß sein für
komplexe lebensformen wenig später wird
es mit der erde dann wohl auch ganz zu
ende gehen doch wie genau läuft die
zerstörung eines planeten ab ein
britisches forschungsteam möchte jetzt
mit hilfe von radiowellen überreste vom
planeten leichen aufspüren doch sind sie
überhaupt auffindbar oder werden sie
komplett zerstört tricks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal aktiviert die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen forschungsteams weltweit sind
sich nicht sicher wie es genau mit
unserer erde zu ende gehen wird fest
steht nur das schicksal unseres planeten
hängt von der sonne ab in 5 bis 7
milliarden jahren wird sie sich zu einem
roten riesen auf plänen ihre oberfläche
wird sich dann wahrscheinlich zwischen
den derzeitigen bahn- unserer erde und
der venus befinden dann hat sie den
wasserstoff in ihrem kern aufgebraucht
dann wird sie modellen zufolge wohl
nicht nur merkur und venus verschlingen
sondern wohl auch die erde zerstören da
schon lange zeit vorher wird es mit
allem leben auf der erde zu ende gehen
schließlich wird die sonne immer heller
und größer und auf unserem planeten
würde es viel zu heiß für komplexes
leben berechnungen zufolge könnten schon
in einer milliarde jahren koch
temperaturen auf der erde herrschen und
selbst mikroorganismen dürfte es dann
langsam aber sicher zu heiß werden die
sonne selbst wird als roter riese
gigantische mengen an materie ausstoßen
letztlich bleibt dann nur noch ihr
innerer kern als sogenannter weißer
zwerg übrig in der fachsprache auch also
weitwurf bezeichnet dabei handelt es
sich quasi um sternleichen die sich am
ende der entwicklung von sternen bilden
doch weil sie über keine zusätzliche
energiequelle mehr verfügen können sie
langsam aus und enden als schwarzen
zwerge damit es dann das letzte stadium
eines weißen zwerges erreicht hierbei
ist die oberflächentemperatur so weit
gefallen dass weder sichtbares licht
noch wärme abgestrahlt werden das
besondere dabei
dieses stadium hält quasi ewig ein
britisches forschungsteam hat sich jetzt
auf die spannende suche nach
vergleichbaren schicksalen gemacht mit
hilfe von radiowellen wollen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus warrick planeten leichen aufspüren
diese haben dann ein vielleicht
ähnliches ende durch gemacht dass der
erde erst noch bevorsteht und es gibt
verschiedene varianten das blatt
sterbens kleiden können zum einen
nämlich zunächst einmal kruste und
mantel verlieren werden dessen ihr kern
noch als image körper übrig bleibt
zumindest für eine gewisse zeit in einem
anderen szenario endet ein planet
vollständig auf einen schlag das
forschungsteam aus bauer sucht ganz
konkret nach weißen zwergen die vom
planeten leichen umkreist werden
der weiße zwerg namens gd 262 ist 150
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt und
wurde einigen hinweisen zufolge einst
von einer erdähnlichen welt umkreist den
aktuellen modellen der fachleute zufolge
wäre es vorstellbar dass ein solcher
planeten kern 100 millionen bis eine
milliarde jahre bestehen könnte
bis er dann für immer endet mit hilfe
von radiowellen könnten solche kerne
aufgespürt werden
die erklärung dafür klingt einleuchtend
zwischen den planeten kern und einem
weißen zwerg befindet sich ein
magnetfeld der kern enthält metallische
bestandteile und verhält sich wie ein
elektrischer leiter es wird strahlung
erzeugt die nach ansicht des britischen
forschungsteams in form von radiowellen
aufgespürt werden können
dazu müsste waren radioteleskope auf der
erde entsprechend ein tunen doch den
fachleuten ist auch bewusst dass dies
nur unter optimalen bedingungen möglich
ist denn die hypothetischen planeten
kern lassen sich nur ausspielen wenn sie
nicht zu weit weg vom weißen zwerg
entfernt sind wenn sich die planeten
kerne allerdings zu nahe am weißen zwerg
befinden werden sie zerstört schließlich
herrschen dort enorme gezeitenkräfte die
gravitation des weißen zwergs würde die
planeten kerne zerreißen auch das
magnetfeld müsste optimale eigenschaften
vorweisen damit das aufspüren der
planeten leichen überhaupt gelingen kann
denn es darf auf keinen fall zu stark
sein da der planeten kern ansonsten in
den weißen zwerg getrieben wird große
hoffnungen legt das britische
forschungsteam auf eine bestimmte region
diese befindet sich zwischen dem merkur
orbit um die sonne und dem dreifachen
sonnen radius also übertragen auf den
anderen stern diese zone bezeichnen die
fachleute in ihrer aktuellen studie als
besonders aussichtsreich radioteleskope
am greenback observatorium oder dem
arecibo in puerto rico könnten sich bei
der spannenden suche als nützlich
erweisen wenn es den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern damit tatsächlich
gelingen sollte die ein oder andere
planeten leichter aufzuspüren würde das
der fachwelt super spannende
erkenntnisse liefern
so bekämen wir beispielsweise hinweise
darauf wie wir uns unser sonnensystem
nach dem ende der erde vorstellen können
und jetzt
habe ich eine ganz besondere bitte an
euch googelt nicht mehr sondern posiert
clixoom ist jetzt offizieller partner
von ecosia der suchmaschine mit der er
bäume pflanzt um den klimawandel zu
bremsen der link ist hier unter und in
der video beschreibung da unten mal
gucken wie viele bäume wir
zusammenbekommen über den link werden
nämlich die kriegs und bäume gezählt
packen also in euren favoriten packt den
auf den homescreen oder sonstwo reden
und jetzt habe ich noch einen tipp für
euch fünf fakten über die planeten
unseres sonnensystems die playlist
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
mit seinen coolen animierten videos
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran